good morning believe nation today's
messages be true to you over to you big
sean man you just got to stay true to
yourself you know never try to follow
the trends that's when you get lost in
the sauce man you gotta do what you feel
man and be creative and don't be scared
to be yourself and always keep that
faith you know I've been in the darkest
times in my life man where I didn't know
what was gonna happen it was flat broke
anything you could think of man I've
been through it and like you know you
got to be strong enough to make it
through and it just makes it that much
sweeter when everything starts going
right so I love this message because
there is always a temptation to
compromise who you are because you think
you can make more money or be more
successful and I'm talking here and live
in New Orleans there's a crazy
thundershower happening I hope you guys
can hear the audio fair but a super
common this temptation will always be
there there's there's a path that you're
taking that is you that is true that is
something you feel happy and proud about
and there's always going to be
temptations to move you our paths will
be off course because you think it can
be more successful because you think
they make more money but it's not really
true to who you are and what you have to
understand and and you know I still get
the temptations myself and I may still
not fully have internalized it although
I like to think that I have you have to
realize that your true success your true
success will come when you are always
true to yourself instead of trying to be
somebody else's version of you if you
see this like short term opportunity to
think it can make a lot of money and
work with a client or or you know be
somebody who you're not the long term
it's not going to work out and let me
give you an example there was a client I
work with who I I took long to deal with
them because I worked with the agency
before and had a good relationship and I
wanted to help them out like I wanted to
help them out I didn't want to say no
because of the relationship I had but I
wasn't comfortable with the deal because
they wanted me to promote something for
them and and I don't promote stuff right
I don't get on youtube and say hey you
gotta go buy this this product and they
weren't super on board with how I wanted
to do it and
that's the point where I'd say no forget
it I don't care how much your money
you've given me I'm not gonna just be a
promotion chill for you guys and I said
yes because I wanted to keep the good
relationship with the client that I had
the agency client that I done worked
with before and we we had an agreement
to do to two different videos and I did
one video and it was okay in the second
video stop before I started because I
didn't like the direction and you know I
ended up saying listen guys I'm I need
to charge you to take you for free I
don't even care this isn't working out
for us and it looks bad on me it looks
bad for them a lot of waste of time and
I knew at the beginning when I knew at
the beginning I shouldn't take me on
that deal and so you'll always be we'll
always be tempted to step outside and
you're not doing something because it's
outside your comfort zone right that's
something you want to really be
conscious up are you not doing it
because you're just scared of doing it
or because it's not true to who you are
actually are nuts that's a big part of
self-awareness that hopefully you have
we can recognize the difference but if
it's something that you feel is not true
to who you are then don't do it and have
the courage to understand that in the
long run that's going to make you a more
successful business person a happy or
human being and able to contribute more
to the world thank you guys so much for
watching my question the day for you is
I'm really curious to know an example of
when you took on an opportunity that
wasn't true to you that you thought you
could make some money with and it didn't
work out leave in the comments below
share your story because I think it
helped inspire others as well thank you
guys so much for watching continue to
believe and i'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot events vessel
morning express to keep me going our
quick burn more disgraceful TV